socialism is preferable to capitalism as
an economic system that promotes freedom
equality and prosperity that was the
proposition
at an in-person soho forum debate held
on sunday april 18th
in the villages florida ben burgess a
philosophy professor at georgia state
university perimeter college
and a contributor to jacobin magazine
spoke in support of socialism
his long-term political goals include
giving workers control of the means of
production
through labor cooperatives and
redistributing wealth and power through
direct democracy in the workplace
and prohibiting wage and salary labor
gene epstein director of the soho forum
former economics editor at barrons
and a former senior economist for the
new york stock exchange
argued against burgess and socialism he
contended that free markets already
allow for worker co-ops and that if they
were that popular and effective
they would be more widely adopted than
they are currently
he also objected that burgess's proposed
ban on wage labor is a direct assault
on individual rights and reveals the
coercion
behind socialist economic policy the
soho forum which is sponsored by reason
conducts oxford style debates meaning
the audience votes yes no or
undecided before and after the event the
winner is the debater who convinces the
most people to switch sides
at the start of the event 8.6 of the
crowd
agreed that socialism is preferable to
capitalism
76 disagreed and 15
were undecided here are ben burgess and
gene epstein
in a soho forum debate on socialism
versus capitalism
sam peterson of libertas served as
moderator
the resolution is socialism is
preferable to capitalism as an economic
system that promotes freedom equality
and prosperity
and with that uh could we please welcome
to the stage ben burgess
thank you
and many thanks to jean
and to the soho forum for inviting me
it's been an interesting weekend among
other things
um i've definitely seen more golf course
uh golf carts in the last two days
that i had the previous 41 years of my
life so you know
that's definitely something so
approaching this i'm keenly aware
that the villages is not exactly bernie
sanders country
and that most people who follow the soho
forum
are libertarians i also know that there
are lots of people
on all ends of the political spectrum
yours mine
lots of others who primarily approach
debates
as opportunities to cheer with the
person they agree with has
a nice charter phrase and to crow about
how the person they disagree with was
destroyed
uh with that the chances that people who
like me
will think i've done that to gene and
the chances that people who like gene
who think we'll think that he's done
that to me yeah right around 100
and will remain right around 100
regardless of what either gene or i say
tonight
that said i also know that
there are many many people who come to
events like this
because they're genuinely curious
open-minded people
who even if they have poor socialism are
genuinely curious
about what the best case for socialist
ideas look like
and they're not content to just argue
with some cartoon caricature of what
socialists think
and in what follows i'm going to try to
talk to those people
i don't want to just talk to the you
know few people here who agree with me
or give my youtube producer forrest
something to clip later
i want to try to make my best case to
you
because even though i'm perfectly aware
that it's unlikely
that all 200 shouldn't change of you are
going to
experience road to damascus conversions
and
fill out dsa membership applications
tonight
uh i do think that it's possible
that i can leave you with uh with
something to think about
and to make you think that there really
is something on this side of the
argument
so i'm gonna try to take all three parts
of the proposition seriously
freedom equality and prosperity
but i'm guessing that i'm going to need
to do the least work
out of the three to convince you that a
social society could be more equal
than what we have right now we live in a
society where the average ceo
makes hundreds of times as much as the
average worker
and truly wealthy individuals make those
quote-unquote average
ceos look like peasants jeff bezos has
told interviewers that the only way he
can think of to spend all the money he's
made from amazon
would be to go into space meanwhile the
men and women who drive his trucks and
work in his warehouses
often resort to peed in bottles because
they're afraid that if they walk to the
bathroom and back
they won't make the demanding quotas
that bezos enforces through constant
electronic surveillance
he doesn't need to worry too much about
his terrorized and subservient workforce
unionizing
because as we just saw in bessemer
alabama he could effectively utilize
economic blackmail
that's a nice job you've got there 15
health insurance
shame if something happened to it and
that's threat is effective
in a society like the contemporary
united states where people like shane
patrick boyle exist
boyle is a diabetic who died when not
enough people donated to the gofundme he
set up
to pay for a month's worth of insulin a
society where jeff bezos and shane
patrick boyle both exist
is extraordinarily unequal and i'm sure
that even many of the libertarians
in this audience would have no trouble
believing that a different economic
system
could be dramatically more egalitarian
maybe gene will despite those dispute
that last claim but even if he does
i don't think that's where the real
action is going to be this afternoon
the reason i don't think that is that i
don't think anti-socialists
are usually motivated to oppose
socialism because they don't believe a
socialist system could be more equal
than capitalism
instead i think they oppose it because
they don't think it would be as
prosperous
or as free they think that if the
capitalist system involves the unequal
distribution of riches
socialism would be in a more equal
distribution of crumbs
and they think that we can only get from
capitalism to socialism
by doing things that violate economic
freedom
those are the main ideas that i'm going
to try to push back against
this afternoon first let's sort out some
definitions
capitalism at least in the original
meaning of that term
is a society divided between a
capitalist class that owns the means of
production distribution
exchange and so on all follow convention
and using the abbreviation the means of
production
and a working class with no realistic
choice except to rent themselves out
to the capitalist class that's what
louis blanc
meant when he first invented the term
capitalism in the 1850s that's what the
socialist left has always meant by it
and it's what i mean by it uh now i
understand gene is probably gonna use
the term a bit differently
i'll wait for him to lay that out for
himself
first let's talk about what socialism
might mean
uh because uh historically the socialist
movement has been a very
big tent it's included socialists whose
idea of socialism is that the state
would just own everything
and it's included socialists who are
also anarchists and it's included many
points in between
libertarians are sometimes surprised to
hear this but historically the
overwhelming majority of people who call
themselves anarchists also call
themselves socialists
what all of these kinds of socialists
had in common
for all their differences was that while
they recognized the transition from
feudalism to capitalism was important
progress
definitely an increase in freedom and
prosperity and even an increase in
certain dimensions of equality
they also weren't satisfied with
capitalism
they wanted a version of modern
industrial society
that would no longer be divided between
a working class and a capitalist class
because there would be some sort
of social or collective ownership of the
means of production
so what form of social ownership do i
advocate
well believe it or not i'm not an
ideologue
at least if an ideologue is someone who
formulates a vision of a good society
from first principles and sticks to it
no matter what
i'm interested in learning the lessons
both positive and negative
from all the societies that existed in
the 20th century
soviet-style economic planning was very
good at rapidly churning out tractors
and tanks
and thank god for it or else hitler
might have won world war ii
uh but it also faced calculation
problems
it was very bad at coordinating
production with fine-grained
consumer preferences as my friend
bhaskar sankara puts it
it was all thumbs and no fingers
and even if we imagined a better version
of the soviet union
one where that economic model was
combined with free speech and real
multi-party elections
such that whichever party won a majority
in parliament got to appoint the head of
the state planning office gospel
that version would be hobbled by many of
the same problems
so that's not what i advocate but
libertarians who accurately point out
soviet union faced calculation problems
tend to try to stretch the point wildly
beyond what the empirical evidence
really supports
and say that the government running any
enterprise
is going to lead to such problems the
fact is
that there are sectors of the economy
that western democracies have quite
successfully planned outside of the
market
health care is an obvious case state-run
health systems in countries like canada
and the uk
aren't perfect i've got a whole list of
ways they could be improved
but there is a reason that they're so
wildly popular
that even conservative politicians those
countries have to at least pretend
to want to preserve them or they would
never win an election again
another obvious example is education
even many charter school enthusiasts
will acknowledge that some of the best
education results of the world are in
finland
a country where every school is public
i'd also nominate energy and broadband
uh
as industries of a type unlikely to run
into calculation difficulties
if they're planned by the state but i'm
perfectly happy to say that if we want
prosperity in other words
if we want there to be enough to
distribute that our more equal
distribution is going to be a big
improvement
for people currently holding the short
end of the stick we probably do need a
market sector with price signals and
firm failure
even if i want to big welfare states the
price of failure isn't destitution
and begging for your basic needs on
gofundme
so far what i've described is just
social democracy
what exists to varying extents uh in
countries like norway
denmark and sweden where capitalist
property rights have been rolled back
in some domains with many positive and
civilizing consequences
but where the fundamentals of the
economy are capitalist
but i want to go further than that i'm a
socialist i want social ownership of the
means of production
even in the rebated market sector so how
could we do that
well if we need private firms they could
at least be worker owned private firms
on the model of the mondragon
corporation in spain
or its equivalence in the emilia regatta
area of italy
where pay scales and operated agreements
are democratically determined
at annual or bi-annual mass meetings
day-to-day management
is at the hands of managers who are
either directly elected by the workers
or appointed by an elected workers
council
and to ensure a long-term stable
domination of the private sector by such
firms the banks that give out grants to
start new businesses would be
nationalized
so would this arrangement be more equal
than what we have now
of course it would at the world's
largest worker-owned firm mandragon
the maximum allowable difference between
the highest paid lowest paid
worker member is 11 to one and many of
the member cooperatives within mondragon
insist on must lower differentials this
is the country spain
where the ceo to work or pay
differential is 143 to 1
and mondragon has to compete for
managerial and technical talent
with regular capitalist corporations
in a country
where every private business was
organized like mondragon those
differences would be lower
that doesn't mean that everyone would
earn exactly the same salary firms would
need to offer
worker members financial incentives for
all sorts of purposes
but if you have to convince the majority
of workers to approve a pay
scale you're just not going to get the
difference
that you get between what bezos pays
himself
and what he pays the people who work at
his warehouses
so far we've covered equality and
prosperity what we have
into of course is the thing that really
makes libertarians tick
which is liberty they think that if we
you know
it might be sad if having a society that
respects property rights leads to a
wildly
unequal distribution of resources and
opportunities and life outcomes
and they might hope that it won't work
out that way and they might have all
sorts of reassurance stories to tell
themselves about how a really truly free
market wouldn't work out that way
but at the end of the day they think
that if poverty and inequality and
extreme alienation and worker
exploitation are the price of freedom
it's a price worth paying but
what's all too left unexamined that
calculation
is what kind of freedom we're really
talking about and whether
on reflection that kind of freedom is
the kind that matters the most
many libertarians will define their kind
of freedom
in terms of the non-aggression principle
this is freedom against interference
with your person or your property
and look i have no trouble understanding
why rights against interference with
your person
are important i'm sure i have lots of
ground with libertarians in this
audience
uh when it comes to the right of
consented adults to pursue whatever
sexual romantic relationships they want
without socially conservative
interference to use whatever drugs they
want to
and make whatever family planning
decisions they want to
without harassment and legal barriers
and mandatory ultrasounds
but let's take a much harder look five
minutes
five minutes okay at the claim that it's
wrong to aggress
not just against your person but against
your property and the means of
production
what kind of property is yours well it
can't be whatever kind of property
you're legally entitled to because if so
libertarians could have no objection to
legally mandated redistribution
you just aren't legally entitled to the
property claimed by the irs
instead as matt brudeg points out what
we're really talking about is the
property that you're morally entitled to
and the real issue at stake between
libertarians and redistributionists
is it whether it's wrong to interfere
with whatever people are morally
entitled to keep
a tautology if there ever was one but
which redistribution
of resources is morally just one theory
of distributed justice
is that everyone is entitled to whatever
they can get from market interactions no
matter how unequal the starting places
of those interactions
but if you want to convince me of the
moral superiority of that theory
over theories of distributive justice to
emphasize regular human values like
fairness and solidarity and giving
everyone a way to flourish in life
all i can say is that all of your work
is ahead of you
instead i would suggest the kind of
freedom that matters most
is freedom from unreasonable domination
by one person over another
the kind of freedom we should care the
most about is our freedom in practice to
disturb the course of our lives
and it should be obvious that
redistributive social democratic
programs greatly enhance this kind of
freedom
in a society where you can lose your
health insurance if you lose your job
you're a bit less likely to get a tattoo
or a nose ring your boss doesn't like or
express opinions he doesn't like
or talk back when he asks you to do
something you don't want to do
in a society where labor laws favor
strong union protections over the
property rights of employers you're a
bit more likely to take the risk of
getting your picture taken marching down
the street
in a protest march for a cause that your
boss hates
these are important kinds of freedom
another important kind of freedom
emphasized by political theorists going
back to ancient greece is civic freedom
the for your freedom to help shape
the institutions that govern your life i
care about that and that's one reason
i'd rather live in a capitalist
democracy like the united states
rather than one of the capitalist
dictatorships the united states has
propped up
in latin america uh but
i also don't think that a kind of
democracy that stops at the door to
workplace
is good enough a society where some
people have no realistic choice but to
accept jobs
where they have to pee in bottles to
make their quotas and some people
already have private jets
and ponder upgraded to spaceships maybe
an improvement over slavery and
feudalism
but it's not enough we deserve better
oops yeah hope everybody hears me okay
uh thanks ben and getting right
to it i'll be arguing that even the
deeply flawed capitalism we have now
heavily distorted by government
government interference on behalf of the
powerful
is preferable to bend socialism
in promoting freedom prosperity and
equality
and if ben would join me in rolling back
crony capitalism
freedom prosperity and equality could be
radically enhanced along with ben's own
aim
for enhanced worker ownership of firms
let's start with emphasizing that
private property rights
in the means of production under
capitalism
consists of wide open choices about the
way firms are owned
and organized ben strongly favors
worker-owned firms
run democratically and they already
exist
in the u.s as he himself said
back in the 1980s the pro-capitalist
weekly
national review published an article
strongly
endorsing worker ownership i'm quite
familiar with that article
since it was written by me
when i covered the worker ownership
movement in the 1980s
we heard much about the mandrakon
corporation in spain
an immense worker-owned firm that ben
also
celebrates it was built up by the
workers themselves
with virtually no government help in a
country
much poorer than the us
yet four decades later we see no
worker-owned firms
on the scale of mundragon in the u.s
according to ben if you work in a
conventionally structured capitalist
firm you are
quote here i'm quoting him
subject to a totalitarian level of
control
of your every action unquote and in
return for your labor you are paid quote
poverty wages ben has also written
that quote worker cooperatives do about
as well
and last about as long as traditional
hierarchical firms
once they get going unquote
so if ben is right then given what must
be a huge
reservoir of anger about working under
totalitarianism for poverty wages and
given the track record
of worker-owned firms you'd expect
workers to use
their financial power to make monitor
guns the dominant mode
by now to clarify what i mean by workers
financial power let's review a few
readily
available figures ben has mentioned
quote libertarian economist gene epstein
as having emphasized that low-income
people do
control a massive chunk of the wealth of
our society when all of their incomes
are pulled together
unquote which ben goes on to call a true
statement on my part
to elaborate on the truth that he
graciously acknowledges
consider that the bottom half of the
population accounts
for one-third of all consumer spending
and the bottom 90 percent
for nearly four-fifths since i assume
that ben would agree
that the fat cat capitalists belong in
the top 10
that means the workers in the
lower 90 percent collectively control
nearly four
fifths of the consumer dollar now take
wealth which is defined as
assets minus liabilities according to
the federal reserve data
the lower 90 percent holds 37
trillion in wealth including trillions
in stocks and bonds
and more than 8 trillion in real estate
that could be converted to cash
via second mortgages this financial fire
power
could establish mandragons nationwide
through any number of strategies take
the classic capitalist tactic
the consumer boycott the profit margin
of non-financial corporations
has been ranging from 13 percent to 17
again the lower 90 accounts for nearly
80 percent of all consumption
now say we target certain firms with a
sustained
consumer boycott that denies these firms
20
of the normal revenue so if you do the
math the boycott would then turn
their profits into chronic losses
driving them into bankruptcy
and making it possible for workers to
buy them up for pennies
on the dollar the funds for acquisition
could come
from part of the trillions the lower
ninety percent already hold
or perhaps from the more than a trillion
held by labor union pension funds
or the tens of trillions held by unions
worldwide these are all conventional
capitalist maneuvers totally acceptable
under capitalism ben has actually
recognized
that boycotts can be effective in
achieving their goals
but he fails to see the role of boycotts
in achieving his own goals
he writes quote that geographically
diffuse customers
encouraging each other to engage in
long-term boycotts
of a long list of companies for a long
list of reasons
detached from any realistic strategy or
even well-defined goals
simply isn't in the same category as
those
other boycotts unquote
but for anyone serious like ben about
worker ownership
the strategy would be quite realistic
with a single quite well-defined goal
when ben speaks the difficulties of
motivating quote
geographically diffuse customers he
seems to have forgotten
his own claims about the the anger of
the lower 90 percent
who work under totalitarian conditions
for poverty wages
or the potential of worker-owned firms
to thrive
once they get going socialists like ben
could surely reach these geographically
diffused customers
to grassroots movement movements amply
supplemented
by social media and they could unleash
all this passion
once they clarify the goal of the
boycott and the odds
of its success ben has also objected
that achieving work ownership
through capitalist means isn't feasible
since most new ventures fail
but in this case i'm not talking about
new ventures but about buying up
established ventures
for very little and then once they
become co-ops underwriting their
longevity through workers favoring these
firms as consumers
similar to the way consumers have
preferred products bearing the union
label
but again i'm using the boycott as just
one example
say that that twenty percent of the
consumer dollar could be committed to
patronizing worker owned startups
since capitalist investors have awesome
respect for the power of the consumer
dollar
there would likely be no difficulty in
getting any number
of conventional sources to back these
ventures
another problem in ben's view is that
quote it's easier
to attract investors for businesses that
can reward investment
with ongoing investment shares
but it's a common practice to issue
different classes
of stock that would leave voting rights
exclusively with the worker owners while
otherwise permitting
outsiders to retain ongoing shares or of
course
bonds could be issued to outside
investors while exploiting the huge tax
advantages
on borrowed funds that the federal
government already makes available
to employee stock ownership plans
ben has also objected the worker-owned
firms can't compete with established
firms
since these firms pay poverty wages but
the aggregate data revealed that in 2019
all private sector firms spent an
average of 75
000 per employee in compensation
a lot of that average is of course
soaked up
by the inflated pay of the executive
class
and just as ben says the worker-owned
firms would of course
save fortunes on that inflated pay so
worker co-ops could easily compete and
probably pay their workers more than
most workers on
earn at mondragon of course
another obstacle is that most workers
may not want the headaches of owning and
operating
their own firms the unwillingness of
workers
to follow the marxist playbook is as old
as marxism itself
and in response socialists keep
resorting to the coercive
power of government in keeping with that
disastrous tradition
ben wants quote to nationalize a few big
banks
unquote and then direct them to bankroll
worker ownership since i want to end
the banking cartel run by the federal
reserve
that enriches the powerful i strongly
object
to any centralized authority command
commandeering
scarce funds in this way ben surely
rejects
such scruples especially especially in
view of his lofty goal
but he should still be troubled but the
old contradiction
of radical change from below being
implemented by the iron fist
of government from above he should
recognize
that any radical change worth having
should be actively implemented by the
people it's supposed to benefit
he should also see this strategy as the
best way to achieve his own goals
instead of having to convince a majority
of the electorate to vote for worker
ownership
a massive worker ownership movement
could be built
from a minority in the capitalist
marketplace and if ben is right
that this is a better way to spend one's
working life the worker-owned sector
should soon win over the majority to the
force of its example
but ben might also be plagued by the
feeling
that he's selling a used car that most
workers
don't want a 2016 pew research survey
of workers reported that half of
respondents said they were very
satisfied with their jobs
while another 30 percent reported being
somewhat satisfied
which hardly sounds like angry people
working for poverty wages
under totalitarian conditions but
visionaries like steve jobs were never
deterred
by surveys and i'm not trying to deter
ben i'm only asking him to recognize
that free market capitalism offers him
clear ways
to turn his vision into a reality
and that his only real obstacle and that
his vision
may not be that inspiring to those he
hopes
to inspire ben's preference for the iron
fist
of government is the reason he and i are
taking opposite sides
in this debate one dark part of his
vision
especially dark part depart is that
he would specifically outlaw voluntary
agreements
between individuals and firms to work as
wage and salary
employees even after worker
co-ops become dominant so in this
key respect ben's concept of freedom is
disturbingly
different from mine and may be different
from yours he advocates a form of
socialism
that will put freedom prosperity and
equality under siege
just like the old socialism did
let's assume that a socialist party wins
a national election
and the government makes ben's socialism
a reality
since wage and salary employment would
soon be outlawed
the the government would no doubt put
all such firms and workers
on notice that their days are
permanently
numbered since there would be resist
could be resistance to this edge
the government would have to be willing
to threaten the offenders
with jail and ben not only wants to
nationalize a few banks
referring to the finance sector as part
of the quote
commanding heights of the economy he
writes
that finance would be quote moved out of
the market
entirely unquote so he would shut down
the nearly 50 billion raised
annually through crowdfunding and the
several hundred billion
allocated through various forms of
venture capital
he regards it as an improvement to place
finance
in government hands since finance would
then be
under democratic control
but very little can happen in any
economy unless funds
are available to finance it and to pick
up an
objection raised by journalist conor
friedersdorf
we might ask how easy will it be
to get the democratically run finance
agencies to fund the expansion plans
of firms that produce muslim prayer rugs
and korans and uh and the building of
new mosques
friedrich friedertos asks quote would
you prefer
a social society in which birth control
is available
if and only if a majority of workers
exercising
their democratic control ascents or
would you prefer
a society in which private businesses
can produce birth control
in part because individuals possess
economic
rights as producers and consumers the
preferences
of majority of people around them be
damned
unquote the question applies to the
related
issue of freedom of speech and press
would you prefer
a social society in which dissenting the
journalism is available
if and only if a majority of workers
exercising their democratic control
agrees
or would you prefer a society in which
private enterprises can produce
dissenting journalism the preferences of
a majority of people
around them be damned
so at best our freedoms will be thwarted
by the tyranny
of majorities but we don't have to push
this decisive objection because in
practice
elected representatives and their
appointees will
exercise most of the real power
directly confronting this issue
ben has written quote the heart
of democratic socialism is an
acknowledgement
that private sector authoritarianism can
be as much of a threat
to meaningful freedom and equality as
authoritarian
government policies unquote
our most beloved living president barack
obama
might correct ben on that point
according to an article in an august
2014 issue
of the british newspaper the guardian
quote
quote new york times reporter uh
james risen who faces jail over his
refusal to reveal a source
has called president obama the greatest
enemy
of press freedom in a generation as
left-wing journalist
glenn greenwald has pointed out obama
used
the 1917 espionage act to criminally
prosecute
more journalists including james risen
than all
previous presidents combined so here's
just one
key difference between the
authoritarianism of government
and the authoritarianism of the private
sector the worst
mark zuckerberg of facebook can do is
de-platform you
the worst barack obama could do is lock
you in a cage
and if he and he made it plain that he
was quite prepared
to do just that if as ben says
the heart of democratic socialism is to
see no meaningful difference
between these two forms of
authoritarianism then democratic
socialism
is badly in need of a change of heart or
even
a heart transplant it was an outrage
when the tom woods show elite facebook
began to great arrest
by frightened fascists at facebook for
dissenting statements
by some of its members but that offered
an uh an opportunity to a competitor
named miwi
but if ben gets his way and obama is
president
then he'll choke off all funding for me
we because
uh if he's prepared to jail us he's
certainly prepared
to to cut off funding so free access to
financing
uh without free access to financing you
have versus no
chance of exercising the rights of free
speech
and free press now take prosperity the
force that brings prosperity is
innovation
or what economist joseph schumpeter
called creative destruction
ben thinks as long as people can be
offered another job they'll agree to
giving up their current job
to allow creative destruction to happen
but since people naturally
resist change imagine the response if
steve jobs
sought funding for a smartphone that
would that upended
so many different industries the
financial planners will have at least
two perfect excuses for rejecting any
projects they don't like
first most new ideas don't work out
second the economic reality of scarcity
there is never enough to go around so
the planners
will easily reject any proposals they
don't like
and in steve jobs case he'd probably be
rejected
right away because he might adamantly
insist on employing
wage and salary workers so freedom and
prosperity would both be under siege
under ben's system of socialism and on
the issue of equality
as noam chomsky has pointed out you can
find income in
equality in a prison where power is
quite unequal
and political power will be more unequal
than even under our flawed system
of capitalism which is preferable by far
to what ben proposes in terms of freedom
prosperity
and equality because we have so two
two minutes because we have so many
avenues of private funding
dissident publications like jacob and
magazine reason magazine
books like ben burgess and the debate
series like the solar forum can persist
because we have private funding and
reasonably functioning
consumer and capital markets uh
innovation that brings prosperity
can and can persist and even flourish
and on income inequality the turn toward
capitalism in countries like china
and india has lifted hundreds of
millions out of grinding poverty
and has therefore meant a narrowing of
income inequality
narrowly but certainly the most
important equality
political equality will mean that the
political
that the power of the few to dictate
to us through that power over financing
will mean a a great decline a great
widening
of political equality as mentioned if
ben would join me in rolling back crony
capitalism we could give workers
more access to new jobs uh if they lose
old ones
and more access to higher paying jobs
therefore thereby reducing
income inequality and enhancing the
prospects for working ownership
we could reign in the federal reserve
whose policies
clearly foster wealth inequality and
inequality of power
and maybe ben will join me in fighting
for the radical rollback of state power
making it harder for politicians like
obama to threaten dissonance with prison
and harder for the government to
intimidate and co-opt
big tech ceos like mark zuckerberg
thanks
thank you very much gene ben you have
seven and a half minutes
all right i could try to be quick
because there's a lot there to get to
uh first point i want to make is that
barack obama uh who's not beloved by me
uh
could uh could fight could prosecute
james risen uh the one thing that he
would not be able to do
is fire random public employees uh
who who agreed with james risen because
public employees have free speech
protections in our society that private
employees typically
do not i would also point out that i'm
very confused about where he gets this
idea
that i want to um eliminate gofundme
this came up in his previous debate with
my friend bhaskar sankara he said uh
you know he he said somehow when bhaskar
said we want to nationalize
banks uh he interpret that as we want to
nationalize gofundme
and bhaskar said you know what like it
finally came up said no i don't want to
i want to get ready to go fund me where
are you getting that and i said the same
thing
last time i debated gene on dave smith's
show so i'm very confused about where
this idea comes from
okay what have i said what i have said
is that i want an economic system
where the division of society between
workers and capitalists has been erased
through social ownership of the means of
production
i've argued that a grounded and
realistic instantiation of this vision
might look like an extremely advanced
version of social democracy with the key
difference that the remaining market
sector
would be composed of worker-owned firms
gene doesn't seem to like the first half
of that vision although he hasn't really
told us why not
and he thinks the second half could and
should be achieved
without violating any capitalist
property rights
simply through building up a network of
worker-owned firms within the existing
system
and using consumer boycotts to bring
down the remaining capitalists
so there are two claims there a could
and a should
let's start with the should gene's
normative claim is that it would be
wrong
to break about workers control through
political action because this would
violate property rights
i argued against the conception of
freedom that that assumes in my opinion
statement
and all i could say at that point is
that i have yet to hear a response
on the second claim the descriptive
claim the social change uh
can happen more quickly or effectively
through the use of consumer power
that's just not what the empirical
record shows
uh we're holding this debate in florida
state where last fall donald trump won
the election but the 15
minimum wage ballot resolution won by
more
uh five minutes ben no surprises there a
higher minimum wage has long been wildly
popular but ask yourself a very simple
question why didn't floridians
accomplish this goal by using their
consumer power
instead of waiting to accomplish it with
politics why did they only
patronize companies that paid at least
fifteen dollars an hour when they roamed
the aisles at
uh publix or winn-dixie i i used to live
in florida
uh they had raised the wage floor that
way with no state intervention necessary
does the fact they didn't do it this way
show that florida voters don't really
want to hire minimum wage floor that
they're you know refusing to follow the
higher minimum wage floor playbook
uh like gene said about workers and the
marxist playbook
uh or think about one of the most
important expansions of human freedom
in american history in the last century
the end of the doctrine of coverture
where many of the legal rights and
obligations of a married woman
were subsumed by those of her husband
was this hideous restriction of women's
rights ended by mass refusal of couples
to legally marry
perhaps instead go into lawyers to draft
contracts that replicated certain
aspects of marriage but without
coverture
uh one could imagine in 19th century
gene epstein insisted that doing things
this way was the only way to bring about
an end of coverture
without violating the freedom of
contract of men and women who had
voluntarily gotten married the old way
but of course curvature didn't end that
way and of course floridians didn't get
their 15
wage this way and of course the end of
the division of society between workers
and capitalists
is it gonna happen that way uh when
we're making life decisions like getting
married or starting businesses
most of us realistically will take the
path of least resistance
work within the institutions of life as
we know it
instead of worrying in that context
about how we think those institutions
should be different we make these
decisions not as engaged citizens
brought together at the ballot box
to pursue collective action but as
atomized individuals shepherded along
by considerations more pressing to us in
the moment
and that's nowhere more true than where
we go shopping while we're at it
uh segregation didn't end primarily
because of consumer boycotts although
the civil rights movement did use them
and i'm not against using them
as one of many tactics to bring about
more worker cooperatives
um that didn't happen any more than
slavery was ended by
abolitionists building up networks of
free labor cotton farms and boycott
slave plantations as the primary
mechanisms
uh these martin luther king's key tactic
was used in sit-ins to violate
capitalist property rights and then
further kirby those property rights with
you know by successfully advocating for
the civil rights act
of 1964 without which i think we all
know there would still be plenty of
whites only signs
in restaurant windows you can object to
this as rand paul infamously did
on the grounds that the most important
freedom is the freedom of business
owners to do whatever they want with
their property
but you can't plausibly argue that
social change occurs more quickly and
effectively
when its advocates abstain from
political action and only use consumer
power
two minutes following cotter's free
cutter i could never say conor's last
name
connor f uh following conor f
gene has argued that economic democracy
would endanger the rights of minorities
but if he thinks this would happen not
due to work or ownership which
he likes if it comes about the right way
but due to
grants from us publicly owned banks is
the primary form not exclusive form but
primary form of finance and new
cooperatives
in my democratic socialist vision all i
can say is that we should be
deeply skeptical of that vision status
zoning boards and liquor boards
already exist but somehow or another we
still have kosher restaurants being
routinely approved for liquor licenses
in a predominantly christian society
we still have mosques being routinely
approved for by zoning boards
in a society where islamophobia is a
real problem
and we still have libertarian magazines
to end to advocate
all of these things delivered every day
by our publicly owned
postal service so this i don't think
is a compelling worry i think a real
disagreement centers on one issue
whether stamping out the savage and
immensely destructive
levels of economic inequality that exist
in our society and giving working people
far more control over their lives on the
job
is more important than respecting
capitalist property rights i think it is
thank you very much
gene you have seven and a half yes well
correcting ben on the current should
as i i hope riley implied
i don't think that working people are
interested in the used car
that ben is trying to sell he just got
through
talking about the savage inequality the
suffering of people
and yet and then he suddenly talked
about the atomization of society and
how can you reach these people i mean
again the problem is that maybe
secretly ben believes his own bluff is
being called
the point is that if there is indeed a
working-class
misery nationwide as ben likes to allude
to
then it's not difficult to tap it to tap
this energy
to point out the way forward more or
less that like
martin luther luther king did when he
said let's boycott the buses
and yet ben seems to veer from um being
a marxist firebrand
to being a cynic about what is possible
in society
but in fact if you take as marcus marx's
firebrand
rhetoric seriously then these
opportunities are staring him in the
face
it's a little bit of course ugly that
deals with boycotts
not just with boycotts by the way ben
you have
80 of the consumer dollar you've got 35
trillion
you've got all that anger out there
presumably the
savage uh inequalities and the and the
lack of power that workers get
well then go for it and yet ben
refuses to because the next thing you
know
he's talking about the atomization of
society
and people only vote for well then maybe
people
don't want what you're selling then uh
so the real test would be try to organ
try to we don't have a mondragon in the
u.s
built in a much poor country try to
build it roll up your sleeves
get out of the uh try to inspire others
you want to stay in your ivory tower
go ahead now with respect to gofundme i
mean there's
also there's this gesture which is that
oh well you can have a little bit of
capitalism a little bit of independent
financing you just can't have any
venture capital firms
you you and by the way we're going to
keep the federal reserve we're going to
keep all the centralization
a financial power that that ben and i
should both object to
but of course i guess i could ask ben
hypothetical what if
what if if gofundme is the only way to
finance something
financially uh to in and and ben's
society
then uh what if it grows to five
trillion dollars
what if it could become so i'm now you
know because it's under control
because there are so many other ways but
the point is that there's this this is
a little bit of capitalism you know you
play with that that's good
but you know don't let it get too big
because then then we socialist will get
upset
so so we'll we'll let you keep go fund
me but we won't let you keep all the
other ways
in which people get financing and start
their own enterprise i i mean i mean
with respect to obama and i know
and and changing the subject with
respect to whether people could be
protected
from the first amendment or not um
that's that that's a separate issue that
we might be able to discuss but again
the the the uh the uh the act
under which obama was indicting people
you could get imprisoned
and indeed you could get executed the
the alien that
that act had executed the rosenbergs so
it was
just an indication that even a nice
politician like obama is willing to use
his power give him the power
enhanced power over finance and and he's
not going to tolerate
any dissent these are realities that are
staring
should stare ben in the face given
what he's proposing uh the uh
a little bit i mean with respect to the
atomized individuals
and the uh what what the other one was
had to do with my idea
that if you uh leave it to a vote in all
cases
by the way obviously most of us will not
have any time in the day
to vote on all the enterprises that
people want it's not we'll obviously
have to have
elected representatives making up their
minds about who gets funded who and who
doesn't but if we even
we want to accept that fantasy again i
know ben is suddenly talking about
the real world in which people don't
have to take it to a vote
in which you can start a deli you can do
what you want you can exercise
that freedom but ben only wants to leave
you with a little bit of gofundme
although i can guarantee you that if
gofundme becomes so
popular because there are no
alternatives that it grows to five six
trillion dollars
ben is gonna shut it down and uh no no
twenty trillion dollars bet at what
point you're gonna stop it
no never fascinating to hear you tell me
what i think okay well
well that's wonderful okay then then ben
is gonna and then then i guess
let a thousand but i don't know why he's
gonna prevent venture capital from
happening because
because that funds businesses that he
doesn't like because he wants to make it
a criminal offense to work for a firm
as a wage and salary worker and so and
so he doesn't want to allow that
so he's going to have a government that
is going to be
endlessly on the prowl to suppress
our misbehavior uh and
that that way lies a dystopia i don't
even know if ben is going to stick to
his plan
with respect to to not allowing wage and
salary labor to happen
i mean the reason why we might want it
even if
ben's fantasy happens and workers get
enthusiastic about his idea which he by
the way he's not the least bit in
selling them because you're just a bunch
of atomized idiots
on the other hand of course you're
filled with savage anger but
uh you're a bunch of atomized idiots
and therefore i don't need to bother
with you to advocate what we can do with
a consumer dollar and with all the
trillions that you're
holding uh but but what but if i would
be perfectly happy to live in that
society
if indeed that's what people voluntarily
want
that's what they create just like they
created von dragon
so that's fine but ben but then then i
might say
look a lot of these companies are kind
of mismanaged i i've been part of co-op
apartment buildings i've been part of
landlord
apartment buildings in new york city do
you know i actually prefer the landlord
apartment
because there are people who take over
who are nutty who make crazy decisions
or mismanage so i might say
i would like to work for that guy as a
wage and salary worker
is that okay ben is going to say no go
to jail
go to directly to jail this is not
allowed
in a socialist society and so again
i even think if i might over
psychologize that ben
is a little bit fearful about the
seductiveness
of actually working for a capitalist
sperm and working under those
circumstances
and clearly clearly he doesn't trust
seemingly doesn't trust people to share
his anger
about all that totalitarianism under
capitalist firms thank you
so we are now moving on to the 30 minute
question and answer portion
if you have a question please line up at
one of the two microphones in the back
but before we do that would either of
the speakers like to ask a question for
each other
one question for ben you have a question
for me i do
uh then can you hear me here yes okay go
ahead
yeah uh so i'm curious about your
interpretation
of uh of the claim about atomization
because
about the claim about atomization
atomization because
it seems to me that what i thought i
said was that
it is realistic to organize a democratic
majority at the ballot box
and that this is a more effective
strategy than
hoping to get it done through consumer
power i don't think that's calling
people idiots
i think that it's saying that there are
certain paths to social change that are
more
realistic than others although they
certainly include
persuading a majority so could you say a
little bit more about why
i think how it is that you got the idea
that i was i was calling people idiots
or i didn't think i could convince them
i think i
i take it back about the idiot part of
it ben apologies a thousand times over
i'm i'm i'm only trying to say that that
i i i
a socialist analysis would say that
people have certain things in common
and great leaders like vasco sankara or
ben burgess
can articulate to them those common
uh feelings and grievances that they
have
and render them and say look this is
what you have in common you 90
you work under totalitarian conditions
you uh
you take orders all the time you're
miserable it's wretched
just like you said and therefore i i
would think that those people should
listen to you
if it resonates if there's validity in
what you say
and then the other benefit is that
voting voting for something in a voting
booth
is very different from actually living
it and implementing
that's what we did during the 1960s and
70s we didn't wait to vote for it
we voted to live it to actually embody
it
and so again that's why i'm suggesting
to you as a good
marxist as a good socialist uh recognize
that this atomization doesn't have to
last
because according to you what people
have
in common is this misery of working
under a under capitalism so that's a
common problem
that's all that analysis is as old as
marxism itself
go for it and yet you refuse to
and that's my problem with you refuse to
see that
that that the ways of going about it are
staring at you in the face
uh if you use the power of the consumer
the power of finance
that's what martin of the king did he
organized
according to grievances excuse me it's
not the primary thing that martin luther
king did it's like a tactic that he used
but it wasn't about the primary tactic
it was the most effective tactic that's
in part what martin luther king which
you can also do but you don't seem to
want to and i wonder why you don't seem
to recognize that the atomization can be
overcome
by simply articulating to these people
the common misery that they all
suffer from it's a very marxist view may
i ask you my question ben i'm curious
about this
uh with respect to mondragon uh i read a
very sympathetic
portrait of mondragon uh and uh
and but one of the things it pointed out
to is that the growth of mondragon
has by and large been fueled by uh by
the expanded employment of wage and
salary workers
now this now i i believe by the way i
would comment that that
while i'm wall for worker co-ops one of
the contradictions in the work of co-op
is that is that the worker owners are
often reluctant
to give up their ownership and now again
this is what is
fueling the expansion of montrecon the
the
the increased employee employment of
wage and salary workers you do want to
outlaw that in your social society right
for starters
and and on top of that then doesn't it
disturb you that monitor gun is growing
based upon that kind of corruption
that's my question
all right uh so first of all just to
make sure that we're clear about this
for the record
the overwhelming majority of people who
work for madragon
are voting members that's compatible
with say that recent growth
uh has been of contractors and of course
we live in a capitalist society
uh where that's uh that's that's an
option there's red disincentives to take
it it's very unsurprising
uh but it's still i think madrigal
remains
as a model of a very successful firm
where where you have democratic worker
ownership now anjian's question
about outlawing certain kinds
of wage contracts i think that uh
i think that yes i'm totally comfortable
with that
and it perhaps might be cheating to uh
to turn this into a question but i would
be
uh i'd be very curious about his
thoughts
about labor contracts that we already
in the society that uh that exists right
now i would give the two examples
of minimum wage laws and sexual
harassment laws
uh that we already outlaw uh get a
minimum
we already outlaw labor contracts where
the wages are too low we do that
without constantly roving around for
people to put in prison
uh as as if that were the only way that
we could enforce some regulation
we already outlaw jobs where you have to
accept the advances of the boss
as a condition for working there people
are already not allowed
to enter into those contracts i'd be
very curious
if gene thinks that those
uh prohibitions should be maintained or
if he objects to those
as much as he objects to labor contracts
that take away people's democratic voice
and vote in the workplace
and if he does object to one but not the
other what the difference is
i i guess i i i have to sort of finesse
the issue a little bit
because if we go down the road of the
sexual harassment of the workplace and
all the rest of it
uh then i should have invited somebody
from the new york times
not a bona fide real live socialist such
as yourself
i can only say ben that that there were
over a hundred
million people 140 million people
in this country who work under totally
legal
and and non-threatened wage and salary
agreements that's what i did most of my
life
and so it's quite radical for you
if you take over to say to these 140
million
your days are permanently numbered you
can persist in this
you're gonna go to prison so i i have to
finish the issue by only saying
that i did not see anything wrong with
the wage and salary
agreement that i had uh and uh
and i don't see anything wrong with with
140 million
wage and seller agreements that are
pretty much set certainly
nothing wrong in the sense that i would
make them
a crime as you would and i
and i believe that you would make them a
crime because you're afraid
of this creeping capitalism indeed you
put you're by the way are perfectly
right
that if we go in the direction which i
don't anticipate
of worker ownership and we might get
tired of it we might find that so many
firms are mismanaged
that wage and salary employment becomes
more popular and that's apparently
a real hellish possibility for you
and you want the iron fist of government
to prevent it from ever happening
this will cause a lot of resistance ben
i myself would be
a part of civil disobedience to anybody
who would tell me
i can't sign on with somebody for the
kind of job i had
as a wage and salary employee that is
true
fascism so notice that he didn't answer
my question
i know i didn't answer your question
about sexual harassment ben
it's true and i didn't ask you to answer
a question about a minimum wage i'm only
trying
to address the larger question which is
that the 140 million people who have
wage and salary employment
should not be thrown in prison but
notice first of all
throwing people in prison for accepting
such employment
is an obvious strawberry for reasons
i've already pointed out
we already have laws against all these
other labor contracts
and we're not going around rampantly
putting people in prison when we have
first
employment we have a hundred prohibited
conditions
so that's just not right clearly we can
enforce regulations
without having to throw workers in
prison for rushing to
accept prohibited arrangements and this
140 million people think
is also not a dis-analogy
between outlawing taking away people's
voice and vote at the workplace
and outlawed labor contracts where
people are paid too little
or accept sexual harassment on the job
before we had minimum wage laws
there were you know surely at least 140
million
people or the equivalent given the
population at the time
who were working in uh in workplaces
where the lowest
paid people could be paid less than that
before we had sexual harassment laws
there were tens of millions of women
working in workplaces
uh with no such uh no such prohibitions
those are just not dis analogies of
course all of these things are radical
changes
at the time that they're proposed
but the question is do we think that
there's any reason why we would need
more of a carceral solution rather than
simply fines and lighter forms of
punishment to the overwhelmed majority
of cases
to enforce this then how we enforce
minimum wage laws and sexual harassment
laws
and do we have any reason uh to uh to
think
that if gene is right right let's say
his prediction is completely correct
that
uh that we have democratic socialism uh
it's a disaster uh because uh even
though our current empirical evidence
suggests otherwise
worker owned firms are vastly less
efficient etc
okay he should have no trouble
convincing a majority of his fellow
citizens at the ballot box
to democratically restore capitalism why
isn't he
confident about that well why doesn't he
believe in himself
and his ability to spread his
libertarian message and win a democratic
majority at the ballot box i've got to
i ca i and you would never
ever let's say we hit let's say you you
you passed the law
i mean and obviously the analogy is that
if you if you're sexually harassed or
you're getting paid a better wage
then you're generally you before it i
had a decent waging salary job
tens of millions of people do you're
going to tell me i can't do it anymore
or indeed not that it's a disaster may i
finish ben again i got
you at it for a while you're you're
going to tell
uh yeah i i didn't say that it's going
to be a disaster only
that it could be an option i there are
decent co-ops in
new york city so many of them are
running by lunatics i would prefer a
landlord building
but now ben says okay once again
if you want to avoid prison then go to
the ballot
ben again my question to you is that
let's say let's say 50 30 million firms
and and 20 million workers refuse the
edict and they continue to work as wage
and salary workers and their reasons we
have
how are you going to stop it unless you
throw them in prison
the same way we stop people from working
for some minimum wage without throwing
people in prison the same way we stop
people
from working at workplaces where there's
sexual harassment
without throwing them in prison the same
way that we enforce every other labor
law
without mass imprisonment this idea that
the only
way to enforce an economic regulation is
by throwing people in prison left or
right
i don't understand where this comes from
and how are you going to stop them
what are you stopping them for you're
giving them a democratic voice and vote
on the job if they choose
not to participate in management
elections of course nobody's going to
force them
any more than people are currently
forced to uh to vote in regular november
elections
what hardship are you seeing people
being given by being given the option of
voting
it's great that you raised that question
ben i'm in the car if i have the option
of voting i would rather live in a
landlord building
the point is that i have the option of i
will have the option of voting
but if somebody advertises look i think
i can manage a firm better in this
industry
and give you wage and salary employment
i'll have the right to sign on
the idea that everything everything has
to happen
through the ballot box that everything
has to happen
by by changing a law and the idea by the
way in your view
that that the wage and salary employment
which is immense
totally unprecedented in terms of what
you're suggesting
in size and the idea that you would
never have to use the force of
government
that's a fantasy but apart from that
again
let me teach you the point is that you
want to might want to work
for a way for an invasion salary
employment because it looks because
others have told you or it looks as
though it's better managed
that's what i would draw why i'd rather
work in the landlord but just ben is
saying
just vote just stay there and vote no
you're not allowed to work for wage and
salary employment
that's forbidden but vote and uh you
know and
and do your thing well you may find that
you can't even do your job well
if it's mismanaged that's why it's
healthy
to let a hundred flowers bloom that's
not
what you want ben and i don't and i by
the way i don't even
know why you're so fearful of it why
shouldn't it why
why why should not happen let's say
people want it
why is it a fear for you
everything you've said literally
everything could apply
to somebody advocating minimum wage laws
in a country where they did not exist
look at how many people
work in workplaces where they have less
uh they make less than this
how are you going to stop people if they
post advertisements
for jobs for less than voices but
somehow
we don't have mass imprisonment
uh in the enforcement of minimum wage
laws and yet
they are by and large we're enforced one
percent you believe in
right you think though that somehow or
another those laws are going to be
enforced so i think this is really a
talking about dating
regulations okay and we enforce economic
regulations through mass imprisonment
okay 89 percent of the workforce ben is
what you're talking about
totally unprecedented and again you
ducked my question
what question do you think abduct
what makes you fear people oh well
that's just migrated you're claiming to
know my motivations
and i obviously don't accept uh your
ability to read by buying to detect well
obviously it is a fear not not not in
terms of emotion
it's obviously a bad thing to happen
it's a bad what
what would happen if it did happen what
what is what happened with what happened
waging salary employment ben with wage
and salary employment
uh then what would happen is workplaces
where people were denied rights that i
think that they should have
so yes i think that in that sense if you
want to call
being against something fear of it
sure so do i but on the other hand
i think go around the streets the
overwhelming majority of people in
florida and the united states
support minimum wage laws for any of
floridians just voted
an hour do you think they're afraid of
what would happen
if we had uh workplaces where you could
earn lower wages that's that's that
seems like a very
like silly question but you basically
said to me as a wage and salary employer
is that
you know better about how i should have
spent my life i i
i depend you may want to what excuse me
that's that's what i basically say well
it is that what you're basically saying
and i
and i suggest to you then that you bring
your case to people
uh and tell them that that there is a
way to a better life but they're too
atomized for you you don't want to do
that okay
anyway they're not if we do it at the
ballot box which is where
we should change what's happened most
effectively in american history they're
not too atomized for that
i think that this equation of thinking
that some strategies for social change
involving democratically majorities
based on persuasion or more effective
than others
means saying oh people are too adamized
this is a caricature
i'll give gene a few more seconds to
respond to that we need to move on to
the audience q a pretty soon
uh please state your question in the
form of a question and address to the
speaker
which you'd like them to answer yes uh
a question for ben please it seems that
ben you keep making the assumption that
a majority of people would like
let's say a minimum wage well a majority
of people would like
a million dollars in their bank account
does that make it right
just because a majority of people want
something a majority of people could
vote
that all red-headed chinese babies
should be thrown in
the atlantic ocean does that make it
right ben
no but i also don't know uh
yeah i'm gonna take a bold stand here
i'm against throwing the redheaded
chinese babies into the atlantic ocean
so
uh which is good i would hate to let
this go by without me saying something
controversial
uh but i'm also not sure where you get
the idea
that i am saying that uh they i didn't
say at any point in this debate i have
never hinted at thinking
that anything a majority of the public
supports is therefore morally right i'm
not sure where that comes from
what i have said is in response to gene
saying
that i am not confident that i can
convince people
to want what i want i've said yeah i am
confident
if we do it in the way that history has
taught us
that persuasion building that majority
coalition achieving social change
is most promisingly done which is
through democratic
mechanisms at the ballot box well let me
let me comment on that again just
briefly again
obviously obviously grassroots movements
people actually implementing change and
being part of it that's a true radical
vision for ben the the ballot box is
very easy
you you vote for a particular candidate
and 90 different things
people often don't even know what the
heck they're voting for at the ballot
but that's
that indeed historically things have
happened to the ballot backs and ben
honors that tradition uh he doesn't want
to to persuade workers uh specifically
because uh he doesn't think that uh
they're
they're uh they can be organized uh
easily enough
clearly that's the problem even though i
clearly think i could convince a
majority but
okay to vote you to a majority
to uh to con to do a consumer boycott 20
to do a consumer boycott again i think
if we look at the track record
it is easier i know you don't think it
should be easier but i think that what
the facts show
is that it is easier for majorities to
work their will
through the ballot box where people are
brought together as citizens to engage
in collective action
rather than through consumer behavior
where there are a great many more
confounding factors
in influencing individual decisions even
among people who by
and large advocate the change in
question you lack the courage
it shows that i think the segregation
example shows that i think many other
examples
you lack the courage of your convictions
or you would be confident that if
democratic socialism turned out badly
you could convince the majority
of your fellow voters to vote in an
anti-socialist party
and again then you are clearly
clearly clearly infatuated with tyranny
of the majority
front mike go ahead you address freedom
and prosperity
but i don't think you address the
equality yeah well
no i only only address the equality
issue in a political sense
uh i don't i think that if ben can't
bend clearly
would it would would cause an assault on
freedom and prosperity
and uh and that it and one out of three
is not gonna should not convince anybody
but of course
as i said even that one out of three is
weak because
the the the political inequality that
would necessarily result
from from the the arrogation of
government power over finance
over labor markets all of that is is
important as well
the word equality also means political
equality
and ben ben's system would clearly
foster
a greater widening of political equality
exactly the opposite is true
yeah exactly the opposite um political
equality is most meaningful
when everybody has the same level of
influence over government decisions
that is ludicrously and on its face
impossible
in a society with extreme concentrations
of wealth
extreme concentrations of wealth always
lead to extreme concentrations
of political influence a more
egalitarian democratic society
would necessarily be one with vastly
more political equality ben has no
interest
in uh in rolling back the cronie
capitalist system
indeed he would tend to enhance it
i think that crodie capitalism
entails capitalism obviously
not what i've advocated microphone in
the back
hey this is for ben yeah are you married
to socialism
or do you want the outcomes that you
believe that they'll get to you and i
just want to provide a little bit of
context
so a lot of socialists they uh kind of
cite the mercatus institute study
and then charles blais he came out and
he wrote a no
uh he kind of rejected what bernie
sanders and the left had been saying
so what he found was it's going to
guarantee that everybody in america rich
or poor
it'll double your tax rate and i'm
pretty sure you're familiar with the
roman rumor study so
you know after 33 you're actually losing
gdp that means that you're actually
increasing poverty
so if you're having really bad outcomes
by
uh the things that you're actually
championing so my questions are
i mean obviously we can even go into
like the quality of it you know i know
there's a bad
who study but my question is if there
are
if you're if your solutions are going to
create more poverty uh worse outcomes
are you still married to that or do you
would you be okay with any solution
that actually got you to the outcomes
that you would like so i'm not married
to socialism
i'm married to jennifer burgess uh so
uh just you know for the record she
should be very upset
if she watched this later and uh and it
didn't say that uh
but uh but no i think that
i'm not married to socialism but i do
believe
and i think i have a justifiable belief
that
socialism is the best way to achieve
meaningful political quality as we just
discussed
that socialism is the best way to
achieve vastly greater
material equality that socialism is the
best way
to achieve democracy uh
and uh you know both at the uh at the
ballot box in a more meaningful way than
we have it now
and in the workplace and so i support
uh i support socialism uh but if it
turned out that i was
i was dramatically wrong uh on all
points that
obviously you know that would change
things for me i'd actually be very
curious
about gene's response to a directly
parallel question because
whereas i'm sure that he would consider
the antecedent
as fantastically unlikely as i would
consider the antecedent
that capitalism could lead to better
outcomes than socialism
but if gene were convinced that
uh that that he's just wrong in his
empirical predictions that the sort of
socialist system that i advocate the
bosca advocates etc
uh actually would lead to um
greater outcome you know better outcomes
would he support it anyway
or is the bottom line end of the day
reason
he supports capitalism in principle
libertarian considerations about
property rights
okay i guess um
i guess there are two answers to that
question one of them is
you know of course if i'm proved wrong i
guess i i'll have to acknowledge
that i'm wrong uh that [ __ ] goes without
saying
i guess i just have to give uh ben a
slightly
old fart answer as well you know
i i was raised in socialism i i
i was a part of the democratic
socialists of america my teens
i was very active and interested in the
worker ownership movement
i saw those people who unlike ben were
actually
working to build worker ownership and
uh and and uh and and i recognize
that that's the way you built something
worth having
i saw the horrors of how government
impose
socialism works whether it comes with a
ballot box or
not if it's elect if it comes through
election
it can still be tyranny so i've been
around the block with these things
and again i can only say that i'm
impatient
with people who like ben who will tell
me well consumer board by cuts
they historically don't work but you'd
rack the courage of your convictions
that the the the anger is supposed to be
manifest out there it was supposed to be
manifested in the 1980s
we don't see any mantra guns in the u.s
maybe
maybe this is not something that people
go
for and then maybe if you're going to
ram it through the ballot box and ram it
through government
it's going to end up corrupt like the
old socialisms
so that's my problem my problem with
wanting to get ben
to to quit with cynical remarks about
history has shown that consumer boycotts
don't work or consumer actions don't
work
but you are in the business of changing
history
that's the tradition that i understood
as part of the left-wing tradition that
i inherited from my mother
but ben is not interested in that much
easier
much easier to think in terms of getting
it voted in
rather than thinking in terms of
actively building a kibbutz
building mandragon doing it in terms of
the actual grassroots way
and showing that people really want it
that
and i was raised in the 60s and 70s
that's that was the ethos of the time
which ben has regrettably tragically
repudiated so
i would not recommend getting your
impression of what i have or haven't
done in my life
uh from uh from what gene has managed to
uh to glean
uh from uh from articles what sorts of
activism i may have been involved in
what i mean
about you actually existed worker
cooperatives like red ebba's the
bookstore
where i always tell people ahem uh to
order my new book
uh reddemas.org you know which is uh you
know which is a worker
uh cooperative uh i do take his point
that gene is much older than me and so
he can claim to have uh have
experience uh but i take great comfort
for the fact
that i have met quite a few socialists
jean's age front microphone
we have um the geometric
rise of the public deploying unions
staying local federal most of which
the employees have little or no choice
whether they belong or not changing a
little bit
of education but it's basically using
union shops
and a lot of the people are getting to
the point where they're not
real happy with this in terms of their
compensation
and the way they're treated over the
since world war
ii the private enterprise
company the unions have gone from
approximately 40 down to now
where it's 7 because they have a
democratic system
they backed away from the immunization
uh yeah i can't explain it although i
think that part of that explanation is
that you're as wrong as wrong could be
about the chain of cause and effect
uh so it's true that unionization
is at a all-time low due to the success
of
uh union-busted efforts oftentimes
involving economic blackmail if you form
a union will shut down the plant
uh like the threats that were just used
so effectively in bessemer alabama
often involving actually shutting down
and outsourcing
uh plants where employers could not in
fact persuade people
uh not not to unionize often involved in
every dirty trick in the book much
including the crony capitalism
that uh that gene so deplores but if
you're interested in the empirical facts
on the ground
the proportion of american workers who
tell pollsters that they would want to
join a union
if they could vastly outstrips
the portion who actually are members of
union's last point about this
i always find it fascinating when
people who are big defenders of
capitalism and big critics of labor
union
say that a closed shop means that people
have lost
their freedom of choice the reason i
find this fascinated
is because if just this one instance
those people are rejecting their theory
of what freedom is that freedom is all
about property rights freedom
is all about freedom of contracts uh
that
it's you know you're not being forced to
do something if you choose to accept a
job where it's a condition
and just in this one case they're
temporarily adopting
my theory of freedom by which
if you're told that you can only get
this job
if you accept this condition that's
coercion that's unfreedom
uh and i would say you can't have it
both ways
either people are as gene says these 140
million people
working as wage laborers either they are
freely
accepting that uh or
it's not the case right that either
that they're accepting that employment
contract means they're freely accepted
whatever the conditions are
of the employment contract with those
conditions or giving up their power
over their workplace or people
are not being free when they voluntarily
accept a job
at a closed shop and the condition is
joining a union or at least paid an
agency fee
but i have never understood how you
could have it both ways
notice uh just a brief comment notice
that even though
ben would want a society in which
worker ownership and control is an
option
he still wouldn't trust people to
voluntarily
go for wage and salary employment second
again
every time i hear ben talk about what
workers want they want unions they want
this
i always i know or indeed ben talk about
how he worked
for this worker-owned enterprise i
always want to say well then
go for the the anger is out to there
uh you i'll i'd be happy to consult
uh all you need you you've got 90 you've
got 80
of the consumer dollar you've got the
power
the anger about totalitarian conditions
is endemic
look at mondragon how difficult could it
be
to do that indeed all ben then tells me
as well
history shows well consumer boycotts
don't work well that's
an uninspiring example yes it's much
more inspiring to talk about what
history shows does work well
recently as florida last november
but i don't think you've met allowed me
to finish what what should be inspiring
is for you to talk about
the totalitarian conditions that workers
are slaving under
the brutality all of the rhetoric that
you like to use
then you would be addressing that 90 and
they would be inspired by your word
i've got a way out consumer boycotts
we've got 30 trillion
that's the way out that's the way to
address them that would be inspiring
if you have the courage of your
convictions gee then if you would like
to respond
so in the summation uh we need to get
some more questions uh in the back
yes yeah so uh ben you were really
offended by income inequality right so
i want to touch specifically on that so
if we did what gene said and
rolled back chronic capitalism and and
really had a
true clean capitalism where um you know
the intersubjective wants of
consumers are are honored much more uh
and we had a
radical increase in standards of living
because of this
but still had income inequality
does that really matter is it just not
envy at that point
i'm sorry you repeat the last part yeah
so if we
had a had much higher prosperity with
clean capitalism uh but still had income
inequality does it really matter at that
point why
would you still be offended by it i got
you thank you uh
so yes i i think that
first of all of course it goes without
saying
that i don't accept the hypothetical
uh that uh that truly clean capitalism
uh would result in this greater
prosperity in fact i think in the real
life in numerous ways every successful
market that's ever exist
has been propped up by numerous forms of
state intervention
uh that without state-backed currency
without limited liability corporations
without intellectual property
protections
all sorts of things that many
libertarians object to uh i think it's
very unlikely that we would have
a form of capitalism that was even close
to the level of prosperity
uh that we that we had right now but
even if i did accept uh the premise
right so it's an interesting thought
experiment
uh if we had much less poverty but we
still had rampant
income inequality uh would that still be
objectionable well it would certainly be
less objectionable because one of the
things
that's wrong with income inequality uh
is that it results
in uh the coexistence of great wealth
and great poverty and
uh redistribution could solve a lot of
that but that's not
the only thing that's wrong with income
inequality
another thing that's wrong with income
inequality is that it makes political
equality ludicrously impossible
uh because concentrations of wealth in
every country that's ever existed
always lead to concentrations of
political power sometimes americans
believe
we can campaign finance reform our way
out of it
not gonna happen concentrated wealth
always leads
to concentrated political influence
another thing that's wrong
with economic inequality is that it
gives some people much more power over
others in workplaces so yes
in the i have to say i find extremely
unlikely hypothetical that you just gave
me
uh then uh that i would think that would
remove one of my objections
to income inequality at least income
inequality as extreme as we have
uh it certainly wouldn't reject uh it
certainly wouldn't
um would remove all of them and i am
very very curious about how far
gene would actually want to go in
removing the state
from the economy and whether he really
believes that
really removing the state from the
economy so we could have some
libertarian vision of clean capitalism
is going to lead uh to
more prosperity as opposed to
realistically quite a bit less
wow okay well thank you for the question
ben uh
briefly again i i don't know i i i
i i didn't invite paul krugman i invited
you uh with respect to that question
uh it's a it's a big topic obviously i
do
believe that under crony capitalism the
rich and powerful
are uh supported uh you even seem to
believe in regulatory capture
you suggested that uh that clearly if we
weaken the state
we go back to something like the vision
of the founding fathers
we'd have much greater justice in this
society because the state is used
uh to protect the powerful that's the
basic uh
nature of the state you pass laws you
pass regulation
the the powerful the money and interest
get interested that's
my mind is just sort of basic political
economy the only thing i would say
however
uh in terms of actually relating to the
larger question
is that what ben wants to do is
foster a a a a dystopia
of gov a greater government power by
giving government
uh power basically overall financing uh
all major allocation of labor uh and uh
and
it would not be even even if it is the
fantasy
of democracy clearly ben seems
to not understand the difference between
freedom and democracy
uh if if 51 of the people vote
on something that's absolutely anathema
i could make something up
then clearly that's not freedom that 51
of the people
vote to crush the freedom of the other
14 49
that's not freedom and i guess
fundamentally i guess
that's where he and our part company
although i do say that it's a fantasy
for him to think that there will be
enough hours in the day
for any of us to know what's going on
with all
all of the government agencies that are
deciding on where the money goes
we can rest assured that the obamas of
this world
will make sure that the money does not
go to any dissenters
whom they don't like and so again he's
going to
could create a society that take it will
take us in
all the the uh in exactly the opposite
direction
i i've said for the sake of the
discussion i'll dispend our crony
capital system
however corrupt it is uh against what
he's proposing
because clearly what he's proposing
would put freedom
uh under siege microphone in the fun
front please uh ben you can address that
in the summation for ben first of all
that probably the majority of which
experiences
i want to know what you would define as
the means of production
because i am not part of the capitalist
class as i think you would define it and
i don't think anybody else in this group
is
uh but we all don't think that i would
consider to be a means of production
such as our computers our instruments
our microphones our phones
and
yeah means of production and remember
that's a
that's an abbreviation you know since
we're obviously also interested
in distribution exchange and so on uh
is is a term that refers to things like
factories farms grocery stores
workplaces right it refers to workplaces
now of course
uh socialists have always thought going
back to
um karl marx and frederick ingles in
1848 writing before the term capitalism
was even even been
formulated by louis blanc that personal
property is something that people have
real rights to
uh that they that property that's
uh that's primarily for personal use uh
is
is something that should be relatively
sacrosanct we can come up with
exceptions uh
you know philosopher kind of edge cases
you know but more or less
uh now is there going to be a blurry
line uh between
personal property and uh and property
in what would usually be considered to
the beads of production or they're going
to be gray areas
yeah of course there are but we don't
want to make the
mistaken logical leap from the existence
of gray areas between categories
to the conclusion that the distinction
between the categories doesn't exist
or is it important you could start out
with uh the you know gentleman there a
few rows up
his head his head i'd say okay he's bald
we add a hair to his head yeah he's
still bald we add a hair to his head
he's still bald
we add it until he looks like fabio uh
and at some point of course he has
crossed the threshold
from being bald to uh to not be involved
uh good luck pitting down exactly how
many hairs
have to be on his head for that
threshold to be crossed
but we all think that that threshold
exists i think when it comes to laws and
regulations
uh there are numerous real world
examples
of distinctions you know being made in
practice about numbers of employees and
so on
those distinctions are necessarily
imperfect given the nature of human
institutions
but i think that they can be drawn in
ways that are if not perfect at least
reasonable
microphone building building on building
on ben's response i would only
again urge him to recognize that private
ownership the right to private ownership
of the means production
by the way be it whether you're
constructing your firm as a worker on
firm or wage and salary firm or whatever
the right to that private ownership
is essential to freedom because
if you give the government any power
over that scarce resource
then they have every excuse uh to uh to
allocate
in ways that intersem that's why we want
a hundred flowers
to bloom that's why we want not only
crowdfunding
why we want to invest in capital why we
want to end
the dominance of the federal reserve
over banking we
we want uh we want as many possible
avenues
whereby people can pursue whatever they
want whether it be it
creating a deli or a hot dog stand or a
printing press
or jacobin magazine that's essentially
the importance
of free market capitalism because
capital
is a scarce resource and if you give the
government the power to allocate that
scarce resource
then that way lies totalitarianism
microphone in the back
all right this is for ben um i fear i
have a pretty good uh
example with me i have a small business
i breed cats
um but me my wife been doing it for a
long time
uh it's not a job that we make a ton of
money at but let's say for example my
neighbor decided
he has a few extra hours in his day one
of the major parts of my job
is to spend two to three hours a day
cleaning the cat room because it's
important to make sure they have a clean
environment
let's say they just they decide to do it
i don't make enough money to be able to
pay them above minimum wage and also in
your
in your i mean not to assume entirely i
would assume
you're in your society that that wage
and salary wouldn't be
amenable there'd be some rules around it
let's say just between us we make some
sort of agreement
what should happen to me what would
actually happen to you
if you decided to make an agreement
where you're paid less
than the minimum wage or where you
violated
numerous other labor laws what should
happen to you if you're a libertarian
who believes very strongly in property
rights uh if
you own a vacant building and uh and and
people squatted that
right what should happen to them i think
in all of these cases
uh we could recognize that there are
ways
of enforcing laws that don't involve
massive
rampant uh imprisonment i think that i
think that focus
you know that we could have very lenient
enforcement we could have
fines uh we could you know we could have
we could focus on restorative justice
and i think that's what you would say
about enforcing the laws that you like
as somebody who believes very strongly
in property rights so for example wants
to use the power of the law to stop
those squatters
i think that that's what i would say
about
uh enforcing you know laws mandating
worker ownership
and i think that's what everybody would
say about
not everybody but everybody else would
say
about minimum wage laws sexual
harassment laws
and every other labor regulation
microphone in the front
not to hog the mic if you don't mind
what what if i decide not to pay those
fines what would happen
i'm sorry what if i decided not to pay
those fines what would you think should
happen
yeah and again what if those squatters
don't pay those fines
right what if people who violate any
number of laws that you advocate
don't pay those fines of course if we
live in a society
that still has imprisonment as a
punishment of last resort
you can come up with scenarios whereby
somebody would eventually be
imprisoned after every other avenue
who's run out
because uh they were squatted
because uh they didn't use their turn
signal
and they refused to pay uh the uh they
refused to pay the fine
uh for getting pulled over for not using
their turn signal
etc so all of these anytime
you have a law sure you can come up with
scenarios where that last resort
is used but i think if we're going to be
realistic about it the
vast majority of the time all of these
laws
are enforced without that and this
objection
cuts both ways to the laws you want to
protect your property rights
to the laws that i want to enforce
fairness and democracy
in the workplace i think ben again when
he talks about
outlawing wage and salary employment
does not appreciate
the quantitative magnitude of what he's
proposing
140 million workers uh tens and
tens and tens of thousands of firms uh
the
what what with respect to uh uh
sexual harassment and minimum wage laws
it's numerically
quite minor and very different
numerically
uh he doesn't appreciate the the
potential
for the cr for the vast amount of anger
that he would be engendering by imposing
that kind of draconian requirement that
that people can't get
a decent wage and salary job
because he doesn't think that this is
the sort of thing
that they should do with their lives
that kind of
arrogant attitude toward the way people
should live their life
could engender anger on the part of the
140 million people
who do it all the time so he's taking on
he's really
playing with fire when he proposes that
and his analogies don't hold up he likes
history historically those analogies are
minor
compared to what he wants to take on in
terms of the law
there might be disanalogies we certainly
haven't heard them yet
despite repeated challenges uh and
the draconian thing being imposed on
those workers
is that they are allowed if they choose
to participate
in elections at the workplace that's it
if if gene thinks
that most people hate being permitted to
vote
if they want to so much that there would
be
somehow even though this was passed
democratically there would be mass
resistance to this
i have not yet tonight heard a reason i
got serious ben
gene gene please respond to this one i
should vote in my co-op
i don't want to listen hold on i thought
your gene
respond to this in the summation i'm
sorry what respond to this in the
submission
we'll have one more question uh
microphone in the front please uh the
question is your reform of democratic
socialism
if you move to the ironbound oligarchy
and if not
why should i be comfortable with uh
you're not handing it over to a small
group of elites you are dramatically
reducing the power of elites right now
in the society that we live in
the needs of production are to a great
extent under the control of a genuinely
small group of leads what we're talking
about is extended
control to the workforce
uh i know of course that we're told that
workers don't really want that
that even if a majority of them voted
for elections they wouldn't really want
it
because if they really wanted it uh then
they would engage
in the consumer tactics the gene wants
uh
i would say that all of the historical
examples that have been discussed show
that those things quite frequently
come apart that a majority uh wants
something
uh even though and will vote for it will
tell pollsters they want it for some
reason the union example he doesn't take
polly data seriously
even though they're not willing to
engage in the tactics
that he's willing to engage in i think
all institutions
are are corrupt i i think that human
beings
are often going to be cruel and
capricious and exercise their power at
institutions
that is why i'm a democratic socialist
because i want to limit the power that
any person has over another person
because to the extent that you're
worried that given too much of a power
imbalance between 82 people
one of them is going to treat the other
one like a little boy with a spider
trapped in a jar
that is a reason to want a relatively
equal distribution of power
which you get by extending democracy to
the workplace
thank you very much with that being said
we now move on to the concluding portion
ben
please take the stage you have seven and
a half minutes yeah
uh so i want to start out by making the
point
about uh coverage sure that you know i
this is not a slam on the moderator i
know it's a thankless task
uh to uh to try to
hurt these cats and to get everything
within the format
but uh that that you know due to the
time limits
you know i wasn't able to get around
earlier because
when we're talking about the end of
coverture marriage
uh which happened due to state action to
reform the institution of marriage you
can imagine
every single rhetorical technique
that my friend gene has used tonight
being used by someone saying hey
if covered your marriage where many of
the legal rights and obligations of a
married woman were subsumed by her
husband if this were as oppressive
as you say it has been if this were as
bad for women as you say it is
then why do women still agree to get
married can't be that bad
uh why can't you just convince them to
mass boycott the institution of marriage
and do it that way
but of course it didn't happen that way
of course
it happened through state action you
could say
with civil rights well if it's the case
that jim crow segregation is really as
bad
for black people as you say it is there
should be so much anger
so why is it that you uh that you
aren't getting black people refusing to
buy every product
uh made by a uh an employer
that use segregation and of course so
they aren't doing that so they must not
really mind that much
of course most people in most
circumstances who are in miserable
conditions
accept those conditions most of the time
they can be persuaded
democratically to enact democratic
change
and the fact that that is a more
realistic route for making that happen
to me
is not cynical gene will refer to any
uh to any empirical observation that he
dislikes
as being cynical to me it's not cynical
it's incredibly inspiring
because what it allows us to do is to
focus on what has been shown
time and time again to be effective
and to focus on using
those more effective tactics
that's a good thing now i want to go
back
to uh the five minute spin
of uh that we started out with
right so i want to think about the
proposition and i want you to think
about whether anything
that jesus said tonight has actually
undermined
the case for that proposition because
there are three elements um
freedom equality and prosperity
on one of them equality we heard a
concession
sure it'd be more equal but one out of
three shouldn't be enough
there's still the other two that leaves
prosperity and freedom
well on prosperity
gene i've got to say i spent about 30
seconds gesturing in the direction of
some sort of prosperity-based objection
i don't really know what that is because
we haven't heard enough about it
uh but uh but certainly
not very much he thinks that it's
impossible i guess you could have
publicly owned banks like actual state
development banks that have worked very
effectively in the real world where
people function as officers of those
banks
like relatively efficient and political
technocrats
being promoted through the civil service
on the basis of objective
criteria uh like you know picking
winners
uh i guess he must think that that's
impossible
uh i don't know why he thinks that's
impossible he hasn't really told us
so the real question i think separating
us is not equality
regina that i seem to disagree it's not
prosperity
where i don't think that gene has made
his counter case
it's freedom that's the real issue is
freedom so let's talk about freedom
if we define freedom
the way that he wants to def that
libertarians define it
right freedom is not interference with
your property
well what's your property we know it
can't be property that you're legally
entitled to because then legally
mandated redistribution
and even legally mandated
nationalization would be fine
it can't be property that you're
currently in possession of because then
that would mean that you couldn't even
recover stolen property
it could only be property that you have
a moral right to
and at that point it's just a tautology
you have a moral right to that property
which you have a moral right to
so the question is which property do you
have a moral right to
it's possible that the best answer to
that question i suppose
is the libertarian one you have a moral
right to whatever property
you happen to accumulate by observing
the rules of a market system that's the
only relevant criteria
but all i could say is that if you think
that that's a more plausible theory than
a theory that emphasizes
regular human values like solidarity and
compassion
and fairness and giving everybody a
reasonable shot two minutes at good life
outcomes
that all of your work is ahead of you
final thought
i read a while back that in 1971
noam chomsky debated the french
philosopher
michelle foucault and that
uh foucault insisted on being paid
in hash for a long time afterwards or i
don't know how long it took them to
smoke it all
every time they broke it out he and his
friends were delighted saying
we're gonna smoke some of the chomsky
hesh now
as a good statist i haven't been paid
for my honorary tonight
in some sort of barter system i'm
accepting payment
in good old-fashioned government-backed
fiat currency
uh but i'll certainly spend some of it
on a nice
uh smokey bottle of scotch one minute
and i'm not going to call it the uh the
epstein whiskey because
my friend gene is unfortunately not
currently the world's most famous
epstein
but i'll say perhaps
what do you like to my friends would you
like a glass of the soho forum whiskeys
that's what i'll be left with
and i hope we all appreciate it what i
want you to leave leave you this
leave all of you with is this
we define freedom the way libertarians
want to define freedom
i've argued that that's circular i
haven't heard response to that argument
30 seconds
if you define freedom the way that i
define freedom
then this could be a problem if for some
reason you think
that abuse and bigotry is going to be a
much bigger problem
in state banks than it currently is in
real world liquor boards and zodia
boards
we haven't heard that case yet but the
more important point
is that if you're defining freedom the
way that i want to define freedom
as freedom in practice to live your life
the way you want
then that means the capitalist
employment contracts
are unfree thank you ben gene you have
seven and a half minutes
well i mean in terms of the actual uh
implementation
of his plans perhaps the
the most telling contradiction that ben
uh
lives with is that he's a big advocate
of mondragon
and yet mondragon was created by the
workers themselves
without any government help but so uh
mandrakon's very inspiring it was
inspiring to us all in the 1980s
and yet and yet we see no uh
companies on the scale of undergone in
the u.s and
manager garden was created in a much
poorer country so
ben says well don't go the way of
mondragon after all they
they're successful and they built it up
through tradition don't go the way of
the kibbutz is
because they were successful they built
it up through tradition uh you
you want to go to the way of the ballot
box and he draws analogies
with the institution of marriage and
with segregation
well both of those issues having to do
with the jim crow's
laws having to do with the laws of
marriage they were very much
bound up with the state and what i'm
trying to
show and i guess ben is mostly agreed
because he initially said that
capitalism
necessarily means that that there were
capitalists and then there were workers
uh what it what uh what i've tried to
show is that clearly
capitalism has a whole range of
possibilities
and that if there is indeed a
groundswell of feeling
about it then capitalism offers the way
and and that ben's analogies are not
valid
uh there should be a hunger for the sort
of thing that he's talking about
and the power of the consumer dollar the
power of of the
30 trillion of wealth that workers have
should be more than enough to bring that
about
and i do suggest that uh that ben
doesn't
want to advocate it partly because it's
a little bit ugly to use capitalist
means
it's it's a conceiving too much to
imagine that you're gonna
that dick you're gonna achieve this
thing through capitalist means and
finally it also tends to imply
that maybe people aren't interested and
again
i'm appalled when ben says well little
that you can't reach them because
you know boycotts are so uh so lacking
in focus well
that don't have to be lacking in focus
if you say this is the purpose
we're gonna target this firm or indeed
we're going to build worker owned firms
and we're five minutes
for five minutes we want a commitment
from you to build it
all of those things are quite obviously
possible through capitalist means
and again mount dragon is in itself
a refutation of ben's views i guess ben
felt i didn't clarify prosperity enough
i i guess when i mentioned steve jobs uh
perhaps that was what i meant to imply
take
take uh take three innovators steve jobs
jeff bezos sam walton
uh we we don't know uh ben ben
seems to think that state-run banks are
going to be the ones
who are going to recognize what's good
and what's bad
well these three were pretty much
self-financing
they came out of nowhere the fact of the
matter is and that's the reason why
so many of the innovative firms are
still in the u.s and why
when you have domination by government
you don't get a whole lot of innovation
innovation is a very difficult and
precious thing
and to glibly say that that's that the
state-run banks are going to do it
they'll they'll suck up all the capital
you'll of course will give you a little
bit of a gofundme but otherwise
they'll suck up all the capital we're
not really going to get very far with
prosperity
because we're going to choke off
innovation finally
again i don't even concede i don't know
whether there would be
greater in equality of income underpins
socialism
it could go either way i do know that
there would be on
injustice stagnation i i do
know that that if ben wants to do all of
these unprecedented things
then he ought to recognize that that
that the legacy of socialism is pretty
appalling
that that we're where we can do direct
comparisons north korea versus south
korea
uh where uh east germany versus west
germany
we get pretty dismal results
uh even when we're talking about
imperfect capitalism
and therefore uh i think that it even
behooves been
just given his respect for history
to recognize that that you want to work
in the grassroots you want to prove
that these systems are possible the
kibbutzim have failed
uh the the to the extent that we've got
anything going on
it's it's become very difficult to
believe that any of these dreams are
worth
uh or worth sustaining and so what ben
really ought to do
is roll up his sleeves and go back to
all that misery that's out there
and use the numbers that i told him
about uh then
the control that they have over the
consumer dollar the control that they
have over wealth and use
capitalist means and recognizing again
that institutional marriage segregation
is not the way to go also recognizing
that what people vote for in the ballot
box
uh you know then i we we uh lots of
people voted for biden
lots of people voted for bush you don't
always know what you're getting it's
it's rather it's not exactly the way to
go especially
when capitalism offers the way
uh two minutes and so i think it's
tragic
that ben doesn't see that i guess the
final thing in terms of my notes
is that ben seems to think that uh
that if i'm working for a worker-owned
firm and i'm unhappy
i can always vote i can always try to
persuade
or some the people in that co-op uh
the the error there are ways but i'm one
thing that's just not
open to me is to opt out the freedom to
opt out which is what
capitalism offers as such a sacred right
you know i i i live in a co-op
building i can vote you know my god
yeah if i can vote what am i gonna
complain well there are some lunatics
running it i'd rather
i i my options are limited so i can't
move
uh but the point is that what ben seems
to think is that
all you got to do is vote all you got to
do is leave it to the majority
and that will solve wool that's that
from the standpoint of
of the free market from one point of
libertarianism is a very
bankrupt philosophy majoritarian fascism
is not exactly a new concept the
even if we did indeed have majorities
running things
the idea that they could tyrannize the
minority or that all you got to do is
vote
all you got to do is push through your
your plans to the ballot box
rather than using the magic of the
market
to go your own way to do your own thing
to prove as
jobs did as basil spirits as walton did
that there are better ways of doing
things
and show the majority of the population
be damned to quote connor friedersdorf
so therefore i do believe you should
vote against the resolution
that ben has been defending thank you
very much
uh let's give one more big round of
applause for our speakers
jane if you would please open the voting
uh if you could all go to sohovote.com
and cast your vote yes no or still
undecided on the resolution
socialism is preferable to capitalism as
an economic system that promotes freedom
equality and prosperity
ben burgess started off with eight point
six percent and ended with six point
five percent
uh meaning a change of negative two
point one five percent gene started off
with
76.34 and ended with 88.17
meaning a change of 11 and with that
gene is the winner
thank you both for coming out i really
appreciate it